hello readers today i'm going to be
talking about text features which is to
say the parts of a text that aren't
just words
we look at text features to get a better
understanding of what the text is all
about although they're not words like i
said text features help our reading
comprehension so what's a good example
of a text feature well let's start with
uh say a map maps are a great example of
a feature of the text that isn't
that isn't made up of words so this is a
social studies textbook
this section is about egypt i've turned
to this page where there is a map what
is this map of well we can look at this
part here this text here over on the
side is a caption it's something they
can tell us about an image and the map
is labeled so it's about the nile river
and how the nile river is fed from
rainfall to the south the water travels
to the north here's egypt up here don't
focus too much on the details of this
being about the nile and stuff really
what we're talking about is here is an
image there is a caption next to the
image reading the caption helps us
understand what's in the image and
looking at the image helps us understand
what's in the caption so we've got maps
we've got images and that can be
illustrations photos blueprints anything
really and if we go back to our social
studies textbook we can see here there's
this image and just looking at the image
on its own we might not be able to tell
what that is exactly but again there is
another helpful little caption
over to the side that says this is an
aerial view of the nile so now we know
what this is
and that can help ground us as we go
through the rest of the text which is
also i assume about the nile river and
ancient egypt
the caption and its picture are two
halves of a whole they're both helping
you understand the other other useful
text features include charts diagrams
and graphs which can include things like
timelines this page here has a table you
can see up at the top this top row is
labeled ancient egypt and then on the
left we have all the different periods
of egyptian history on the right all the
dates associated with those periods
there's also a timeline in this lesson
and this one has a bunch of different
text elements right so we have it's not
a traditional looking timeline but you
can see that it's arranged from top to
bottom
oldest to most recent
those are just some of the many options
that are available to you when you look
at a text remember that when you're
reading a passage it's not just the
words it's everything on the page
sometimes i even like to familiarize
myself with the charts or the diagrams
or the images on the page before i start
reading before i really get down to the
business of reading the paragraphs
because that helps me get rooted it
helps me anchor myself in what the text
is going to be about i look at the
pictures i skim the captions just to say
okay what's going on here cool we're
talking about rivers we're talking about
ancient egypt i'm ready and building
those skills of readiness and being able
to anchor yourself in any text that you
encounter is what's going to make you a
strong reader
you can learn anything
dave it out